There's a weird story that caught my eye recently.
This Ohio man apparently who has a
a farm, who--
I'm sorry, it looks like someone in the audience
has a question, yes sir?
Yeah, hi, this is so weird.
I'm sorry to bother you.
But do you see my shirt?
Yeah, I see your shirt.
Yeah, it's a hand squirting like a mustard bottle, yeah.
Right.
So on the way in, I saw another guy in your audience
who like, I don't know, it seems like he has the
other half of this shirt.
Is there a way to get a shot of him.
He's sitting right over there.
[Conan] I don't see him.
Oh my god, look at that.
(laughter)
Yeah!
(applause)
I was thinking the same thing.
That's so weird.
It's like we're two parts of the same story.
Yeah, that's very cool.
Do you guys, do you know each other or something?
No, but I'd like to know him.
(laughter)
I mean,
we clearly both love hotdogs.
Yes.
And it's not just the shirt.
You seem like a great guy.
Aw, so do you, man.
Thanks, man, I think we'd totally hit it off.
You know, buddy, I think we are hitting it off.
(laughter)
[Hot Dog Shirt] Totally.
Absolutely, yeah.
(laughter)
Okay, guys.
I love, the shirts are great,
but if you don't mind,
we're gonna just move on with the show, okay?
Thank you.
As I was saying, this story in the news caught my eye.
In Ohio, this guy has a farm.
What?
Sorry, but I don't want this to end.
I gotta know that guy.
(laughter)
We were meant to be friends.
That's what I was gonna say.
Could we just sit together?
We have so many hotdog related things to discuss.
Please, Mr. Conan.
(laughter)
Sure, okay, fine, just sit together, sit together.
I got a show to do, please.
Do you mind?
Thank you.
Alright, okay.
Back to what I was saying, okay.
In Ohio, okay, there's this guy and he had a farm,
and the weird thing is he got this idea that he was
gonna rob a bank, and he wanted to pay
for his engagement ring,
so the
(men laughing)
Absolutely.
Well, we couldn't agree more, Nigel, as you know,
we're very excited to be working with you as well.
Yeah, it's been a passion project of ours for years.
Talk to you soon.
What are you guys doing?
What are you doing?
You're not gonna believe this.
We just pitched the documentary about hotdogs to the BBC,
and they bought it.
They bought it.
(applause)
Check it out, check it out.
No, stop.
Guys, stop.
(cheering)
No, no.
No, that's stupid.
The BBC just would never buy a documentary.
There's this notion that the only hotdogs that exist
are these factory made creations,
these artificial tubes that we see in plastic wrapping.
That's just not true.
There is a place, though it sounds like legend
or the imaginings of a child,
where hotdogs, real hotdogs, are created organically,
naturally in a sustainable environment.
Blooming from the earth like fruit in the Garden of Eden.
(laughter)
Here we go.
Here we go over here, look at that.
Those are awesome right there.
Oh that size.
Those will be foot longs a few months from now.
You see here, almost a half dozen right there.
[Voiceover] This forest alone contains over 97
different varieties of dogs with new species
being discovered every year.
That's ready to eat right there.
This out here is done.
This is where cocktail wienies come from.
They grow right in the ground like pearl onions.
[Voiceover] Sadly, due to deforestation,
this is one of the last remaining natural frankfurter
groves on the planet.
But against all odds, the dogs continue to flourish.
Though only two square miles,
it produces over 25 tons of wieners per year.
Oh nice, let's see what you've got here.
Oh, just beautiful.
Oh, my god.
[Voiceover] The main benefit of a trip to Wiener Woods,
you're no longer in that studio in Burbank.
[All] And that's how you get out of a Conan taping.
(laughter)
(applause)